[Applaudissements]
c'est assez caustique ça c'est drôle ça
s'envoie baba dame sa tombe
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour séduire talent
voilà par exemple est-ce qu'il faut être
drôle ce qu'il faut être beau est-ce
qu'il faut être d'avoir les cheveux
longs avoir les cheveux courts avoir
avoir les idées folles qu'est ce qu'il
faut pour séduire talent what you -
[Rires]
j'aime la simplicité de la simplicité
pathak badaboo même ta simplicité si ça
vous avez la simplicité c'est vrai ouais
assez bien ça vous aimez le naturel
voilà j'aimerai yaourt qu'on fait on pas
très bien non mais voilà j'aime bien
savoir parce que c'est vrai que tu
allais vous devez avoir un succès vous
avec les mets pas la beauté de la me
sens bien parce que ça allait pas que
bell et maintenant on adore elle dégage
que chauveau aussi des dégâts c'est vrai
que c'est une bonne comédienne j'ai joué
avec calme
ah oui c'est vrai merci merci moi aussi
ma mère fait des tartes aux fraises
car si numéro quatre faites jean luc
lemoine jean luc lemoine qui est numéro
4 aujourd'hui et est numéro 1 des jeux
je donne pas numéro 4 ça m'intéresse pas
il faut le jouer le jeu c'est là-bas
alors c'est cyrille eldin dans le lda
rapporteur alors il a l'air il a eu un
échange un petit peu musclé avec
dominique besnehard la sortie d'un film